half my family's from the UK and I've
been there plenty of times but they're
from Liverpool
yeah who's from Liverpool my dad oh so
he's good too
where it is
so I I yeah I was born in Wales for all
that stuff and my dad was born you speak
Welsh that's rare yeah yeah that's right
okay 16 of Welsh people speak Welsh yeah
so not very
useful sadly in everyday life it's cool
party trick though if I want to talk
[__] with my mom yeah that's helpful
um yeah I mean UK is nice but also it
does it sucks when you come here and
you're like it should have been us yeah
we should have we should have been this
time yeah you guys are like look at all
these nice buildings yeah so obviously
we share it's such a very similar
culture everything is good you guys are
like the UK but happy yeah
oh it's like the building things got
like five percent worse and everything's
more wet
and watch the price too
and and the roads and parking is [__]
oh yeah
collection that's just rubbish on every
street too well you know it's like
[__] London it was I mean the city
wasn't built for uh trash collection or
cars and then one of my friends took me
in the tunnel and I had to stand and I'm
Too Tall so I'm like curving in this
[__] tiny ass underground
claustrophobic
that's it which is like 150 degrees
Celsius well the first one was built in
like
1800s yeah I was with my friend and
they're like and she was like oh we'll
take the tube it'll be quicker and I get
in there I'm like I would have rather
two more extra minutes in the Uber
and like uh some of the lines make you
feel like you're about to like derail
you know like the central line I don't
know if you've been on the central line
but there is there is this the show loud
oh my God you go on the central line and
you all you can hear is just
for like the entire trip and I'm like
I'm like why is it
I don't know sure it's also like heating
up like gradually over time yes are the
worst Heat Wave because there's no it's
like hard to get the heat out of the
tunnel yeah ventilation well there is
there is ventilation there's some
buildings that are just drill some holes
in it well they have like fake buildings
outside and it's literally like an
entire chimney yeah it's cool but so I
wasn't tripping when I said I was 150
degrees wait wait wait did you go to
Liverpool uh I've been there twice in my
life
where in the UK have you been out of
curiosity Liverpool London where's
Pewdiepie from Brighton it's from Sweden
we went to Summer [__] Allison I've
been um what do you think of Brighton
no
climate Village it was a retirement
village I'm on a raising prices
that like meme where it's like uh you go
to Mexico and it's got the CPA filter
and people are yeah and you're like
that's not really how it is when you go
to the UK it's like actually there's
like a gray filter on everything
because I remember my first like my
first ever experience in Australia I get
off and I like go to the hotel and I'm
like oh [__] this is what the UK could
be like with good weather oh my God like
my eye just opened I was like this is
this is Brian's final potential
everything every building like all the
old buildings because we have Heritage
buildings here that can't get touched I
think I'll sell you this yeah
um they can't be touched but they're all
based off UK buildings that already
existed so all the architecture here is
very similar yeah yeah but better such
good food here as well yeah you really
gotta say that when you guys live in
Japan like the coffee's great coffee is
so good here the coffee yeah the coffee
is just like unreal I love the Coffee
Culture especially because like in Japan
it's like if you want good coffee you
just just need to [__] take a Gamble
and go to like a small coffee shop that
like kind of looks we got [__] I guess
we said coffee [__] in Japan there's
some good coffee places but some of the
comments are like I bet they're gonna go
to Starbucks
Japan likes the traditional uh like
kisoten the traditional cafes with pour
over coffee yeah I don't really like
pour over coffee I just want the [__]
espresso what's the difference like in
terms of taste
um well espresso-based drinks you
normally you can also like turn into
like lattes and stuff but pour over
coffee is normally always just oh it's
all uh okay yes well that's like the
traditional cafes but I prefer like
espresso based drinks anyway yeah yeah
so it's so much nicer I like lattes as
well I don't like Cafe Olay do you guys
really think the food here is nice yeah
I mean it's great but like
as someone that's been to Japan many
times and can go no no Japan is better
yeah
if you move outside everywhere you go
the food is amazing because it's always
like you've experienced the one thing I
did love about the UK was what's what
night's roast night is it Friday night
Sunday night me and Scott won that
because I think you're off having a
holiday after we did some filming me and
Scott like just got drunk one night or
random part of it was great and they had
roasts
and we're just drinking these beers and
eating this rice I'm like man I've had
such a [__] time until I walked into
this Pub and I had a roast and a beer
that's when it all makes sense being
British when you're in the pub and
you're eating the pub food you're like
okay all right yeah I love Pop Culture
outside the pub walls everything's fine
yeah
pubs are the best part of the UK yeah
the pub culture is the best like
especially in like even like London it's
great too you know someone else
some would argue it's the only thing it
is the only culture we don't have
anything else it's like the rest of the
other the other cultures
ah yes yes this is your queen too what
do you mean I mean if I'm like spending
my mom cried when that happened
because my mom's like really British and
she's like the Queen's dead like oh you
gotta go over there and we gotta [__]
like pay our respects I'm like Mom
[Laughter]
I think a lot of quotes I have one
living like grandparent life that's my
mother's grandmother that's all I got
left and she's like she's like 90
something and she's like me and your mom
Grandma we're gonna go over we're gonna
pay our respects I'm like that [__]
cannot get out of bed let alone get on a
plane what do you think she she's gonna
die on the way there mom like she was so
committed thankfully they never did it
but like that's how hot she was about it
she was like willing to risk her
mother's life on a plane to like go pay
their respects in Australia were you
taught to be like kind of passionate
yeah
I don't give a [__] about that but like
in school they're trying to teach you I
think we missed that part of our life
yeah I think that might have been a
generational thing possibly yeah because
before us I think there was like a
comparison where they're like this is
before we're born there was like the
queen came to Australia and there was
like a massive parade and everything and
then she came again like 20 years later
or something like that and I might have
been 15 or 16 and for the parade that
was like 1 100th amount of the people
that showed up to like please and see
her coming on her car and [__] like that
like no one give a [__] yeah when I was
growing up because we were in Wales they
did not talk about them nicely good and
I remember that it was really weird that
I used to see on TV and like they'd be
so positive about it then all the
teachers would be like they [__] suck
they took everything from us
don't support them and I was like this
is very mixed messaging but then
immediately after that lesson they're
like by the way the Queen's coming to
Wales so we're gonna all go outside and
wait for her
[__] with stones in our pockets
oh we waited I was like I was like 10
and we waited outside of a church and I
remember being like Mom why am I here
I've been here for six hours on the
grass and nothing she hasn't showed up
we had a similar thing here but people
got trapped in the mine
we all got a day off school to see if
they'd get these three miners out that's
oh my God I remember that yeah like is
this an Australia yeah it's Australia
yeah in Australia so instead of waiting
for the queen one morning we woke up and
Mum was like today is that because these
guys got trapped in the mines for like
two weeks from a collapse like no school
today we're gonna sit here and watch the
TV to see if these three guys make it
out alive and I was like what happens if
they die we're all watching and also we
got a day off when Stevo and died too we
all got to stay home oh yeah watching
make some Memorial on TV yeah so that's
our holidays
the queen
man I wish you could have lived to be on
cold ones
oh he would definitely come on we were
going to get his son on I think we're
still talking we're talking to his son
about doing something
awesome yeah it's it's really hard to
get to him because you've got to go
through like all those corporate people
you have to go through corporate people
and then you still think you can get him
on through corporate people we got
someone doing it for us I ain't saying
anything we wanted us to go to a the zoo
or whatever and show you around yeah
some [__] like that but then I think at
one point they're like oh he can't make
it on this day like do you still want to
do it I was like no yeah and they're
like we can have him come in for one
minute of the video and show you an
animal I'm like no we want to sit down
with him for an hour and drink a beer
and drink a beer yeah we want to feed
alcohol to the animals that he brings in
how many beers can a snake drink